generically wars of necessity or wars
where I think the vital interests of the
nation are at stake in which there are
no viable alternatives to the use of
force for example diplomacy doesn't look
appealing or attractive or it's been
shown to be unsuccessful sanctions
aren't going to do the trick and living
with a certain situation is deemed to be
unacceptable a war of choice is very
different or a war of choice is usually
has two qualities one is that the
interested state tend to be less than
vital and secondly there are in fact
other policies that are available it
could be diplomacy or could be simply
tolerating a situation or it could be
sanctions or what have you just to be
clear I'm not suggesting that warp
choices are per se undesirable or wrong
or bad but simply they are just that
they are wars of choice and they only
make sense if you believe that the costs
and benefits not only line up so the
benefits are greater than the cost but
also that the costs and benefits of
using military force make more sense
than using alternative foreign policies
well the most obvious one that many
people will recall is Vietnam Vietnam
was not a war of choice the United
States had to fight it was clearly not
central I would argue to the overall
balance say between the United States
and the Soviet Union and the United
States invested a great deal in large
part because it exaggerated the stakes
that were in fact they're so that's the
most obvious contemporary world choice
more recently you had Wars like Kosovo
and Bosnia where again the United States
did not have to intervene are the
interested state were important arguably
there was some strategic interest there
were some humanitarian interest more
than anything else but no vital national
interests were at stake so those are the
obvious wards of choice the most obvious
war of necessity other than the one I
wrote about the first Iraq war i would
say is the korean war in 1950 when the
North Koreans went across the 38th
parallel before that World War two
well two things one is I didn't think
that Saddam Hussein say in 2001 2002
2003 had done anything that particularly
knew that was particularly threatening
to the United States or another way of
putting it I did not think the status
quo that the the Bush administration
inherited in 2001 was per se
unacceptable or or intolerable I thought
that Saddam was saying to use Colin
Powell's phrase at the time was in was
in something of a box he had lost
control over most of the north of his
country you had us and coalition
aircraft flying over the north and over
the south he was really limited in his
sway over his own country we thought at
most he had some biological and some
chemical weapons he had not been able to
rebuild his conventional military after
he got decimated in the previous war
after he invaded Kuwait we did not think
he had anything in the way of nuclear
weapons we did not think he was in any
way associated with with terrorists so
we simply didn't think he represented a
vital threat to us interests in the
reason rather he was quite diminished
secondly there was a sanctions regime an
extensive sanctions regime that if that
was in place and though it had eroded to
some extent and clearly money was
reaching Saddam Hussein that should not
have been and the life that I believe
there were options to shore up the
sanctions regime not to make it airtight
not to make it impermeable but again I
thought we could have improved it so
that again it would have not eliminated
the threat but it would have contained
the threat so essentially I believe that
containment of Saddam Hussein was a
viable and perfectly adequate option
there weren't the great dealer
conversations there were only a few that
I that I recall looking a little bit at
the whole question of sanctions in a
fairly desultory way though the one
moved the Colin Powell promoted work was
called smart sanctions and if you recall
at the time the United States was coming
unto tremendous criticism in the Arab
world also from the left in this country
and around Europe because the sanctions
were alleged to be hurting innocent
Iraqis it wasn't true in my view the
sanctions had all sorts of humanitarian
exceptions and if there was any
suffering that was going on in Iraq was
because Saddam Hussein was causing the
suffering but wanted the sanctions to be
blamed for it was part of his strategy
to undermine international support for
the sanctions but Powell's idea was
essentially to challenge him at that
game so the whole idea of smart
sanctions was to make it possible for
Saddam Hussein to import a 44 larger
range of goods and services that would
not have military consequences to
essentially take away from him the
argument that sanctions were somehow
causing suffering leading to disease and
so forth on the part of Rocky's and we
thought that if we could do that that
that would have the effect and part of
rebuilding regional and global support
for sanctions that was probably the
principal principal set of conversations
about Saddam Hussein
he's also when you asked the question
about Afghanistan he is also embarking
what i would call something of a war of
choice in afghanistan taking a step back
for a second the bush administration
after doing very little in afghanistan
initially post 9-11 its rhetoric got
more and more inflated about afghanistan
so you had the bush administration
talking about bringing democracy to
afghanistan but the bush administration
never resourced that policy so the Obama
administration has come in and
interestingly enough it's increased the
resources you're seeing more combat
troops more trainers and it's decreased
the rhetoric and now is no longer
talking about democracy but instead it's
talking about building a self-sustaining
Afghan government but they're also
talking about taking the fight to the
Taliban essentially what mr. Obama is
doing is making the United States now a
protagonist in Afghanistan Civil War and
what they're hoping is that the United
States can weaken the Taliban and then
provide time and space for the Afghan
government to build up its capacities so
it can deal with the Taliban and it can
deal with a al-qaeda I would core call
this something of a war of choice the
United States could have more modest
goals in in Afghanistan it could also
have more modest means if it was only
going after al Qaeda but the Obama
administration has it's made to
interesting foreign policy decisions so
far want us to establish the timelines
in Iraq and the other is the buildup in
Afghanistan both their significant
decisions the phrase war of choice is a
neutral phrase it's a description all
I'm trying to do is distinguish it from
award necessity but the United States
you can argue whether we have a vital
national interest in Afghanistan we have
a vital national interest in seeing that
Afghanistan is not used as a terrorist
platform I'll a 911 but I don't think we
have a vital national interest in the
quality of Afghan society so the United
States might then say well we're just
going to limit ourselves to going after
the terrorists when we see them we're
mainly going to use well whatever mix of
military intelligence and other
other foreign policy tools we'll put
together all I'm trying to say is in
Afghanistan the United States has come
up with a particular mix of tools and
it's decided it's going to basically
take the Taliban on along with the
Afghan government in a civil war that's
a war of choice now I'm prepared to say
it's a defensible choice and it's worth
trying I am a little bit skeptical
whether it will succeed and my
prediction is that roughly a year a year
and a half from now the Obama
administration is going to have to make
some some additional choices and if I'm
wrong and things are going very well in
Afghanistan one choice will be whether
we stick with it or whether we even
increase our ambitions for example
should democracy building become more of
a goal a more likely future is where
things are not going well in Afghanistan
we've put in extra troops and the
general situation in the country is not
improving and the question that is what
do we do do we put in more resources or
do we perhaps dial down our goals and
that could be a very intense foreign
policy debate roughly in a year
I don't believe that uh I think one or
two of the people in the administration
had a thing about Iraq and it was
mentioned from time to time and Paul
O'Neill if you may recall in his memoir
talked about how Iraq was mentioned
early on and people around the Secretary
of Defense mr. Rumsfeld including the
deputy secretary Paul Wolfowitz people
around the Vice President Dick Cheney
didn't mention Iraq intermittently but
there was no intensity to it and there
was no real opportunity to move with it
it's an interesting historical debate
whether this administration would have
gradually found a way over time to do
what it did be severe rock had it not
been for 911 it's possible but it would
have taken longer and it would have been
far more difficult to galvanize the
support within the administration and
beyond but again coming back to your
basic point pre 911 Iraq was simply not
high up on the on the radar screen
what I believe motivated George W Bush
had nothing to do with religion in the
in the proselytizing sense or anything
like that what it had to do more than
anything else I believe was that he
thought that after nine eleven that the
United States needed to make a powerful
statement to the world to use another
phrase that Richard Nixon made famous
and in other context that the United
States was not going to be a pitiful
helpless giant and for George Bush and
Dick Cheney and Don Rumsfeld and
Condoleezza Rice and others the
accomplishment of ousting the Taliban
and liberating Afghanistan did not take
care of that it did not send the message
that they wanted to it simply wasn't big
enough the way I put it in the book is
it didn't scratch the itch and they they
came to the conclusion they needed to do
something of greater weight and greater
significance and that was a rock and
they wanted to take a rock which had
been a thorn in the side of the United
States and other countries for some time
and they believed they could oust Saddam
Hussein they believed they could
transform a rock into a functioning
democracy and they fill up by so doing
so they would not only send a powerful
message to the world that the United
States was not to be trifled with but
that they could then use Iraq as a model
that would then go on to lead to
political change throughout the Middle
East that essentially this would become
a transforming historical event and
ultimately development that's what this
was about
I've often thought the Dick Cheney was
quite conservative people forget that
because she's such a moderate man in his
manner and in the way he in his bearing
and the way he conducts himself but he's
extraordinarily conservative now in the
previous Bush administration when Dick
Cheney was Secretary of Defense he was
also quite conservative and he and I had
our differences at that time once he saw
me walking around the Pentagon going
over bombing plans being briefed on it
and he complained to the National
Security Advisor and the president about
it we had our differences when Israel
was struck by Iraqi missiles eral in the
early days of the war and Dick Cheney
wanted the United States to essentially
give Israel the green light to retaliate
and I argued against it and I prevailed
but the difference in the previous Bush
administration is dick cheney was the
odd man out you had dick and then you
had George Herbert Walker Bush Brent
Scowcroft Jim Bakker these were all
traditional centrists and Dick Cheney
was essentially outnumbered and largely
went along and he actually also agreed
with the policy if you recall Dick
Cheney even afterwards publicly defended
the decision not quote unquote to march
on Baghdad when people would criticize
it Dick Cheney in this administration
rather than being the outlier was very
much at the court along with Don
Rumsfeld Condoleezza Rice and George
Bush and was Colin Powell my boss who
was the outlier so I believe that dick
cheney was in a position where he could
put forward his more conservative views
and rather than being isolated he was
then right in the center of decision
making and again as I said after nine
eleven his boss the president wanted to
do bold things so Iraq was the idea of
putting Iraq at the top of the American
foreign policy agenda was something that
Bush was very open to because Bush was
looking to do something big and bold and
Iraq seemed to present to him and others
the best option for so doing
I believe after nine eleven the United
States had a window to get more involved
in Afghanistan than it did I advocated
publicly ended up being a front page
story in New York Times I advocated at
the National Security Council meeting
with the President the Vice President
others at the United States should do
more I thought there was a real moment
after the ouster of the Taliban with the
United States if we had put in not
hundreds of thousands of forces but
maybe 25,000 forces and I believe we
could have gotten an equal amount from
the Europeans I mean as they've
ultimately done in Afghanistan as we see
now where they have thirty odd thousand
forces I believe then the 50,000 forces
US and European together could have made
a real difference we could have filled
that vacuuming and there might have been
a receptivity then where we could have
done some serious nation-building in
Afghanistan so the deterioration that
we're now dealing with never would have
come about I can't prove that obviously
in retrospect and even then arguing in
2001-2002 I couldn't prove it then I
couldn't guarantee that if people did
what I was advocating it would succeed
but I did predict that if we don't do it
the sort of thing that we now have to
deal with would come about that ignoring
it or doing the minimum would would
almost certainly lead to an Afghanistan
that would essentially begin to look
like a failed state again and that's
exactly what we have
I believed for two reasons one is the
father-son relationship fathers tend to
give their sons some space secondly
ex-presidents there's an unwritten rule
that ex-presidents give the incumbent a
little bit of a space I think in this
case there was a third thing though and
it's obvious that there was some
awkwardness because the policies of the
father and the son was so very different
George Herbert Walker Bush the pretty
41st president he represented a
traditional what i would call real a
School of American foreign policy it was
a foreign policy of multilateralism of
diplomacy of limited ambitions of
working with international institutions
his son represented a very different
foreign policy of transformational
ambitious almost radical foreign policy
unilateralism a heavy dose a much
heavier dose or reliance on a military
force a real suspicion of international
arrangements you saw it with the
International Criminal Court you saw it
in the realm of climate change we saw it
with the United Nations so in some ways
they represented the fault line of the
American foreign policy debate the
former president the older president
representing the more traditional
realest school that the principal
purpose of American foreign policy
essentially ought to be to shape the
foreign policy of others and his son
representing the radical or more
wilsonian school the idealist school
with the principal purpose of American
foreign policy ought to be to shape the
internal nature of others and this this
debate has been going on for more than a
hundred years in the United States and
it's just fascinating to me that it the
two sides of the debate are so
exemplified by a father and son and it
manifested itself in these two wars with
Iraq this is a these are textbook case
studies that define the the basic fault
line of the American foreign policy
debate
no I wrote an article in The Wall Street
Journal the other day essentially
arguing that we should not criminalize
the policy debate I read all the memos
that have been released by the various
Justice Department officials and what
they did in the way that legal reasoning
sometimes do almost like accountants
they were basically saying the following
forms of activity are not explicitly
illegal or excluded under domestic or
international statute I don't
necessarily agree with the reasoning of
a certainly aggressive legal reasoning
but it seems to me it's not the sort of
thing that gets into the realm of
criminality it's simply aggressive
advocacy if what's more they don't set
the policy they were simply arguing the
policy then it was up to the president
and the cabinet and others to make the
decision about what was going to be
allowed or not so I think this whole
debate about whether to prosecute or
criminalize those involved is really
misguided what we ought to have a debate
in this country is about the pros and
cons of certain types of interrogation
techniques that's a legitimate debate
about what the benefits potentially are
and reasonable people seem to disagree
on that and what the costs are and
clearly this costs reputational into the
United States there's moral issues and
again there's real basic questions about
the efficacy of these techniques whether
they actually do provide usable valuable
information but I don't see this as a
legal issue I see this as a policy issue
and for the Congress in the United
States I don't think we need years of
distraction trying to find scapegoats or
alleged criminal activity i would think
we need to have policy debates and we
need to get on with it because this
country faces an array of challenges
that borders on the the unprecedented i
also think is someone who's been an out
of government in my career it's not a
smarter healthy thing to do to
criminalize advocacy that people are
going to be making arguments and
government and sometimes it may be quite
assertive or aggressive or outside the
box will find that's why you set up
processes to vet these things that's why
you need a discipline rigorous National
Security Council process
i would say Pakistan ought to be near
the top of the foreign policy heap it's
probably the most worrisome and
difficult foreign policy challenge or
national security challenge facing the
administration you've got I don't know
plus or minus 100 nuclear weapons you
have the headquarters so to speak of the
the world's principal terrorist
organizations you've got a government
that is unable unwilling or both when it
comes to controlling its own territory
you've got a government that to some
extent is not a government it's not in
control of it itself what to add it all
up you've got a tremendous gap or
disparity between US interests on one
hand which are enormous and US influence
on the other hand which is quite limited
and anytime you have a gap between
interests and influence you're obviously
in an uncomfortable or dangerous
situation and that's where the u.s. is
with Pakistan it also holds the key to
some extent without Afghanistan so
getting the Pakistanis to deal with this
growing what you might call Taliban
ization of their society which is bad
for Pakistan's future as well as
Afghanistan is something we can edge but
we can't force and we can't do it for
them so we do the odd predator attack
which to some extent helps to some
extent alienates the society the real
question is whether we can build up
relevant Pakistani capabilities because
most of their military capabilities
quite honestly are irrelevant to the
challenge they face they're based upon
some I think largely non-existent Indian
threat rather than the real threats the
Pakistanis face and it's also not clear
to me they have the will there are large
parts the Pakistani establishment that
don't agree that the Taliban represent
an existential threat to their country
or their society so I don't see the
United States doing it Pakistan anything
like it's doing in Afghanistan I don't
see any broad commitment of ground
troops this is the country of 175
million people we're not going to do
that but I can't imagine a war of its
necessity arising in the context of
Pakistani state failure I can imagine a
president the United States conceivably
order
Special Forces or air strikes to deal
with terrorists or I can imagine a
president of the United States ordering
special forces in or air strikes to deal
with nuclear materials so it's not
inconceivable to me that sometime during
mr. Obama's presidency be it for if it
has eight years we could see something
of a discreet you might call it war of
necessity visa V Pakistan a Pakistani
government that rather than growing is
facing real economic problems is going
to be that much worse off in dealing
with its internal political and security
challenges
I don't see it I believe that the
Chinese are preoccupied with employment
with the success of their economy they
know they're an underdeveloped country I
don't believe the strategic culture of
China is also heavily I don't believe
it's a imperialist global challenge I
don't believe the Chinese for example
are going to attack Taiwan because again
with the Chinese know they need are
literally decades of stability so they
can grow their economy they still have
hundreds of millions of people to move
from rural areas into urban areas they
know just how when you develop they are
now if you're asking me 50 years from
now 75 from you yes ml couldn't mature
China take a different direction yeah I
can i can see that conceivably I'm not
predicting it but I can imagine it and
the one thing that worries me about
China's political trajectory is that is
what will motivate its people I worry
that the principal motive in China in
down the road again we're talking in
decades or laga here could be
nationalism and that would be unhealthy
and that's the reason that I believe
it's important that China gradually open
up politically that China can't simply
be a culture based on materialism I
don't believe socialism or communism are
going to be its motives so I do believe
it needs greater political participation
but if I were a US Defense planner a lot
of things would keep me up night night
so we've talked about some of them like
Pakistan like Afghanistan like a rock
like Iran like North Korea China would
not be on the top 10 of that list
for President Bush the first the 41st
president george herbert walker bush I
spent all four years of his presidency
on the staff of the National Security
Council technically I was a special
assistant to the President and Senior
Director for Near East and South Asian
affairs what that boiled down to is I
was his and Brent Scowcroft to his
national security advisor I was his in
Brent's go cross principal advisor on
the part of the world that included
North Africa the Middle East the
israeli-arab situation the so-called
Persian Gulf and all the way through
Afghanistan India and Pakistan through
South Asia so I did that for all four
years for the second president Bush the
43rd president george w I was in the
administration only for two and a half
years from january two thousand one
through june 2003 and there i had two
hats i was the director of the policy
planning staff for the secretary of
state for colin powell and a second hat
i was a roving ambassador for the
administration where i was assigned
specific missions the two most prominent
that i was assigned was first after nine
eleven i was made the u.s. coordinator
for the future of Afghanistan and then
even before that early on in the
administration I became the US envoy to
the Northern Ireland peace process
well for outsiders to be frank it's rare
for careerist and I am NOT a career I'm
not a career foreign service officer or
career military or career intelligence
for careerists that's that's the norm
you serve and as administration's come
and go it essentially doesn't matter for
the most part for someone such as myself
who's an outsider I'm trained as an
academic I've worked for one Democratic
president for Jimmy Carter at the
Pentagon but I work for Ronald Reagan
and I work for both presidents bush but
I also worked for a Democratic senator
years before for outsiders I would think
I'm more the exception by and large
Outsiders come in as political
appointees they tend to have a political
alignment usually if a Democrat
obviously or republican I'm pretty
centrist I think by most accounts I'm a
registered Republican but I I think i
was brought in not because of my
political affiliation but rather simply
because people in a position of
authority be it's a a brent scowcroft
under Bush 41 or Colin Powell under Bush
43 knew me well and simply wanted me to
work with them
I thought it was right then and I
thought it was right now I remember the
the conversations in late februari 1991
which was at the when the battlefield
phase of the war was ending and the
President and Brent stroke of all of us
Jim Bakker Bob gates Dick Cheney
everybody was comfortable with stopping
and the concern was that if we went on
towards Baghdad or if we intervened in
the various rebellions the so called in
to fathers that sprung up in the south
and the north exactly the kinds of
scenarios that we then saw in this more
recent Iraq war would happen and I
remember saying the people that that I
feared that more Americans would die in
that phase of the war then it died in
the entire liberation of Kuwait and
there was simply no but there was simply
no interest in marching on we wasn't
what we the deal we caught with the
Congress it wasn't the deal we'd cut
with the international community
militarily Colin Powell who was then the
chairman of the Joint Chiefs of Staff
talked about what a nightmare it was
going to be on the ground logistically
and coordinating with various Iraqi
forces I remember him standing by the
easel given the briefing in the in the
Oval Office about about that so for all
those reasons george w george herbert
walker bush wanted to keep things
limited wanted to essentially stop and
not have the United States get bogged
down in that type of of a scenario that
was the the idea was to keep it limited
and we thought that we could bank a lot
of goodwill and use that to among other
things go on and perhaps promote a peace
process between Israelis and Arabs which
in fact happened which was the Madrid
Peace Conference several months later
the one assumption that was flawed and
that was wrong is that we we thought
Saddam Hussein would likely fall we
believe that he would be ousted by his
own people for having led them into a
failed war that proved wrong but I think
proved right though was the idea that
keeping a rock intact was a smart idea
because that way Iraq could continue to
balance Iran and we still believed at
that point that
Iran led by these radical mullahs and
the rest was a much greater threat to
the Middle East and one of the ironic
results of the more recent Iraq war is
that Iran is the great strategic Victor
and no longer has to worry about Iraq
instead it is Iran that has tremendous
influence not simply in Iraq but
throughout the Middle East with Hamas
with hizbollah and so forth so we were
playing balance of power politics in the
first Iraq war and in the second Iraq
war the Bush administration of george
george w did not play balance of power
politics and the result is they they led
to an imbalance of power that favored
iran
did something I ask myself a lot and I
wrote more mellow than I can count
making the case both that we had viable
alternatives to going to war but also
about if we were going to go to war how
to do it in a smart way and if we were
going to do and then if we were going to
go to war we had to plan for an
aftermath and how to do that in the
smart way and my frustration is that
virtually everything I recommended at
every phase was ignored or rejected it's
not so much that I wished I had argued
harder i wished i had had more
opportunities to argue it out I've been
in government a lot in my life and you
never win them all you don't expect to
but you really do want your day in court
you want your chance of what was so
frustrating to me about this
administration the second Bush
administration is I essentially felt
that people with my views never got
their day in court that there wasn't the
National Security Council process that
guaranteed that divergent views would
really have their their chance and that
things would be argued out no I have no
illusions that even if i had had every
chance in the world that things would
have been fundamentally different i
don't think it would have happened given
where people where the center of this
administration was after nine eleven and
given the fateful decision by the
National Security Advisor by Condoleezza
Rice and by the President to put
responsibility for the Iraq aftermath in
the hands of the Defense Department I
thought that was a terrible decision
it's a little bit like playing tennis
and having someone not just be your
opponent but calling all the lines and I
thought the Pentagon should have
oversight of the security dimension of
things but should not have oversight of
the overall policy that auto stayed in
the White House it's interesting several
years later it was ultimately moved to
the White House where it should have
been where it should have been all along
so I have tremendous frustrations with
the policy obviously I disagreed with it
I had a frustrations with how the
intelligence wasn't listened to but
again I don't believe given the
political balance or imbalance in this
administration that I would have I would
prevailed regardless of what
opportunities i was given i was given to
make my case
I just come back from Iraq I was there
about two weeks ago my own view is that
the various timelines of getting the
United States out of cities say by this
summer ceasing all combat operations by
a year from this summer and beginning
all US forces out of Iraq over the next
two and a half or so years I believe
that there's no way those timelines can
be met and have Iraq not once again
really descend into a lot more disorder
I simply do not believe that Iraq the
Iraqi police and military forces will be
able and willing to take on those kinds
of responsibilities I don't believe what
the Iraqi Iraqi society has reached a
point where it can be a self-sustaining
orderly place without American forces
there so my hope and my prediction is
that sometime after next January's Iraqi
national elections the new Iraqi Prime
Minister and the president of the united
states are going to have to work out a
new arrangement where essentially the
reductions or draw downs and US forces
will move more slowly and secondly we
will keep some kind of residual force in
Iraq that where there will not be a
withdrawal but my view is if we stick
slavishly or automatically to these
timelines I don't believe Iraq would be
ready for for the responsibilities that
it would inherit if and when we left
not exactly the surge which really
consisted of several pieces there was
the increase in US combat forces there
was the change in strategy which is
probably even more significant away from
offensive so called kinetic combat
operations much more into a traditional
counterinsurgency strategy of clearing
out the enemy and then providing
security to the to the to this citizenry
there was the diplomatic part of it of
buying off a lot of the Sunni tribesmen
xand fighters who had been a directly or
indirectly supporting radicalism and
terrorism so all of this came together
and indeed it was probably the most
orderly decision-making process of the
george w bush's presidency and it showed
were a large outside discipline force
that had adapted its tactics in its
strategy in this case the counter
insurgency could make a real difference
I thought it was in retrospect I think
it was a smart thing to do the problem
now is whether we can use the time and
space that the surge have created to
help the Iraqis build up a
self-sustaining police and military
capability and the jury's out and I
would simply say that probably the best
we can hope for with Iraq is a somewhat
messy future not a future that looks
like Civil War but it also won't be a
shining city on a hill and my view is
that the best way to keep a floor under
Iraq's future so it looks okay is
probably by keeping a residual American
force for for years to come or even
longer now this could become a fateful
set of decisions for the Obama
administration it's ironic that Barack
Obama ran against a rock said it was a
terrible war of choice he is going to
probably face some fateful choices with
Iraq about whether to continue with his
timelines and then if he does my fear is
that then things will begin to unravel
and then he could face again some
terrible decisions about whether to
recommit US forces into a messy
situation
well he's doing things that I support I
believe in diplomacy I don't believe in
talking to that talking to Iran somehow
constitutes a concession or a favor I
think he's right to drop the
preconditions what matters in a
negotiation is not so much where you
begin but where you went so I think all
that is to the good the problem is that
he faces an extraordinarily difficult
situation where the Iranians have gotten
quite far they've obviously already
produced a large amount of low-enriched
uranium if they were to put it back in
their centrifuges and reinforce those
transfer fuses they could produce the
basic stuff of a nuclear device and they
would have to weaponize it so my hunch
is he is offering to change American
foreign policy at a time when the
Iranians are already pretty far down the
path of having produced a the raw
material for a nuclear weapon and it's
not clear to me that the pace of the
pullup diplomacy can match the pace of
Technology and what's slowing diplomacy
down even more is the upcoming Iranian
election but I think he's right to try
this because the two alternatives to
negotiating a ceiling an acceptable
ceiling on the Iranian program one that
we could conceivably live with the two
alternatives are not attracted the idea
of using military force against Iran is
a unbelievably unattractive option
because it's not clear what it would
accomplish and it's also clear the
Iranians would retaliate in some
expensive ways it's all it also would
drive the price of oil up dramatically
something we don't need and it's not at
all attractive to live with an Iranian
nuclear capability given Iran's rhetoric
giving its support for terrorism and
given that it would place the Middle
East on a hair trigger and given that
other countries in the region could well
follow suit and as bad as a Middle East
is Right today one can imagine a
situation that would grow worse to say
Iran is real and half a dozen Arab
countries over the next 25 years had
nuclear capabilities that would be a
that would be a nightmare so I believe
the president's exactly right to try to
negotiate our way out of this I don't
think the negotiations can be expected
to solve this if I solution you mean
come up with an Iran that does not
enrich uranium my own hunch is that we
would have to be prepared potentially to
allow Iran to have an amount of uranium
we could talk about the amount of
uranium they got the production capacity
but it would depend upon i believe the
level of inspections we would have to be
able to convince ourselves to a high
degree that this was all they had and
what they had was not the sort of stuff
that was what that was so-called
weapons-grade but rather it was the sort
of stuff that you would need for a
reactor to produce electricity now I
would feel better if Iraq had the means
in place to produce electricity and they
don't so again you've got to be wildly
suspicious but so far at least they
haven't crossed that red line they've
not taken the so-called low-enriched
uranium up to high enrichment but if
they do then Barack Obama could face one
of the fateful days of his presidency
because either the Israelis might decide
that is intolerable or he himself might
might be pressured to declare it on
intolerable and then act upon it
it's a good question and after less than
four months it's a little bit hard to
tell but this is a president who
obviously listens carefully to his own
counsel he's got people like Bob gates
at the secretary secretary defense so as
I believe a lot of influence he's got a
retired general as his national security
advisor and the personal of Jim Jones
you've got someone like David Petraeus
the central commander who obviously has
tremendous influence both still over
Iraq but also over the conflict in
Afghanistan the chairman of the Joint
Chiefs mike mullen is probably spending
more time in Pakistan these days than he
is in in Washington you've got a
secretary of state hillary clinton who's
active plus you've got any number of
sponsor special envoys i would think the
difference with the bush administration
is you actually have more players here
that you don't have necessarily any
single person who might who might have
quite the the weight say of a dick
cheney but what you have is a large
number of people and the real challenge
for the administration i will think will
be coordinating all these people and
making trade-offs because in addition to
iraq afghanistan you what you do have
the challenge in pakistan you do have
the challenge coming because of Iran's
nuclear program and you've got all the
issues that arise from everything with
dealing with great powers to North Korea
to the global economy to climate change
the swine flu so it's a it's an
enormously crowded foreign policy inbox
and determining trade-offs priorities
sequencing and so forth is going to be a
real challenge for the administration
the world the deteriorating economy
could cause massive problems in terms of
state failure throughout parts of Africa
I also worry about the absence of
economic growth what it would mean for
countries say like like China and its
potential uh stability and I think also
there the lack of trade the fact of
trade is now contracting around the
world rather than growing has I think
unfortunate not just economic
consequences but but political
consequences deal the only upside I can
see on the economic side funnily enough
is the fact that some of the energy
dependent economies which are
essentially cash crop economies like
Iran and Venezuela to some extent Russia
aren't going to have that luxury of
enormous Treasuries and as a result in
the case of Russia they may actually
have to develop a real economy which
wouldn't be bad news and in the case of
places like Iran or Venezuela they won't
have this all these extra resources to
cause mischief and indeed to the
contrary they may have to be more
responsible to their own citizens for
the delivery of essential services and a
standard of living but by and large
those are the exceptions and I think the
struggling world economy will you'll see
the the growth of friction within in
between states because of it and it's
not an immediate crisis but over time it
could be a real drag if you will on on
global stability
actually the same book pretty much power
to persuade was the first edition then
we reissued a second edition which
probably had ten percent new material
and we changed the title so it's a
they're essentially a similar book it
grew out of my time kind of two things
one was teaching at the Kennedy School
of Government and I couldn't find the
book that I felt told students who were
thinking of careers in government but
also can I get this in a second but also
in the private second the book i really
liked and i had a lot of experience
myself working in government what i
wanted to do was come up was produce a
book that would help people figure out
what it is they wanted to accomplish and
figure out how to accomplish it and the
model i came up with was a compass that
everybody had to think about their north
which was their bosses their South their
staff their East their colleagues and
their West which were those outside
their organization but they still had to
interact with how they had to work off
of those four directions of their
compass to help them figure out what it
was they could accomplish and to help
pave the way to to accomplishing it and
that that was essentially the the model
or the structure and I interviewed a lot
of people and looked at a lot of people
and essentially said what what explains
why some intelligent people succeed and
others fail and I wrote it mainly at the
time for people going into government
but I have increasingly concluded that
it it makes just as much sense for
people who are running a fortune 500
company because when you look at what
the world's these people now run or
operate in it looks an awful lot like a
political world they're facing all these
independent constituencies they're under
the glare of 24 7 media and a constant
news cycle they've got to deal with
unions they've got a deal with
competition globally and domestically
they've got to deal with environmental
groups and citizen groups and state
legislatures and Washington DC so if
you're the head of if I say any of the
major financial institutions so you're
the head of an automobile company but
pretty much anything else these days you
are operating in an unbelievably crowded
comp
cated competitive space so the age if it
ever existed when a CEO could live in
some kind of splendid isolation and
issue commands and have those commands
followed faithfully those days simply
don't exist so again I look at the life
of a CEO or someone who wants to be a
CEO and I look at the life of someone
who is either a cabinet chief or an
assistant secretary in some cabinet
department in washington and
increasingly the kinds of political
challenges they face to figure out what
their agenda is a more important to get
to translate an agenda into reality
their worlds look awfully similar to me
and that's that's what I try to do is
come up with tools that would help
people navigate extraordinarily
challenging political environments which
increasingly you find yourselves
to me loyalty has two dimensions one is
to speak truth to power so wherever you
are that one of the things you you owe
it to your conscience you owe it to your
career but you owe it to your boss is to
tell your boss not what he or she wants
to hear but what they need to hear and
you need to be creative but you also
just need to be intellectually honest
and if you disagree you need to disagree
in here is why the other half of loyalty
up though of what you owe your boss is
when your boss decides makes a decision
and it doesn't necessarily go your way
you've got to live with it you you can't
undermine it you can't be disloyal and
you don't want to resign every time you
don't have your way it's something I
actually write about in the Iraq book I
had to live with the question of whether
to stay or resign when when decisions
didn't go my way and my view is uh
either it has to be a very big decision
that doesn't go your way and those are
rare fortunately in life or it has to be
the accumulation of a large number of
medium-sized decisions that don't go
your way and you say hey this isn't the
right place for me but otherwise it
seems to me you essentially part of what
you owe your boss loyalty up is a
willingness to work with them if you've
been hurt out and even if it goes
against you that all you don't
essentially pick up your marbles and go
home go home I mentioned this because in
my experience most people often do
neither a lot of people are afraid to
speak truth to power because they're
feared there's going to be retribution
of retaliation and secondly if they
don't get the decision they want one way
or another they sabotage it they're not
enthusiastic or they don't do all that
they could and should they're not
professional about implementing it I
also say while we're on it there's also
loyalty down from north to south what
bosses owe their subordinates and you
seems to me you owe them their day in
court a chance to make the arguments if
you go against them you you've got it I
think you owe it to them an explanation
as to why and if you do those things I
think you're more likely to get the sort
of behavior you want from your from your
from your staff
you